[Musique]
Honnêtement - ça me manque vraiment, je serais
resté plus longtemps, mais les choses se
passent. Retourner à Niagara Falls est toujours
difficile pour Helen McGinnis. C'est un endroit
où elle a travaillé pendant près de 20 ans.
Beaucoup de bons souvenirs.
façons et je ne sais pas qu'il est
difficile de mélanger les sentiments, elle a reçu
un diagnostic de cancer en 2002 et se demande maintenant
si cela a été causé par le rassemblement de l'un
des herbicides auxquels elle a été exposée
partout où vous voyez la zone de brousse
essentiellement là-bas.  d spray
aussi fuck jeez tu sais Ici je
marche et je peux le goûter et c'est sur
mes vêtements Helen pense que la rafle a peut-
être causé son cancer car il est maintenant
au centre d'une controverse massive
Monsanto qui a vendu l'herbicide pendant 40
ans était  reconnu coupable d'avoir caché
des liens possibles entre le produit chimique et le
cancer, je ne pense pas qu'ils savaient
à ce sujet qu'ils se sont mis en
quatre pour attaquer les scientifiques qui ont soulevé des inquiétudes et à plein et je veux dire que c'est strai  ght commettre une fraude en avant
bien vous croyez ce qu'ils vous disent vous
croyez ce qu'ils vous disent et puis vous
découvrez par la suite qu'ils vous ont trahi
en ne vous disant pas la vraie vérité des
milliers de personnes comme Helen ont
cherché des réponses depuis que des
documents internes sont sortis  qui a révélé
les secrets les plus étroitement gardés de Monsanto,
ces documents racontent son histoire qui
mène au nord aux anciens responsables de Santé
Canada lorsque la rafle est arrivée sur le
marché au milieu des années 1970, il était
considéré comme un produit miracle aura
une application mondiale étendue dans les
plantations l'herbicide tue presque
toutes les plantes  qui avaient été pulvérisés, sauf
ceux génétiquement modifiés pour y résister, l'
ingrédient magique des rafles est un produit chimique
appelé glyphosate. Notre histoire commence en
1976, lorsque la rafle a été utilisée pour la première fois
commercialement au Canada cette année-
là
.  la CBC sur les dangers
de la maladie du mercure a commencé à développer des
signes de meth  intoxication au mercure yl, il
deviendrait éventuellement un haut fonctionnaire
de la Direction des aliments. Le
ministère de la Santé s'occupe de ces questions,
c'est que s'il n'y a aucune preuve
indiquant que le matériau est dangereux au
milieu des années 1980, Ian Monroe a quitté
Santé Canada avec plusieurs anciens collègues.
il a fondé can tox une société
spécialisée dans le conseil en toxicologie
rappelez vous que le nom can tox
deviendra important plus tard dans cette histoire
le chemin de Ian Monroe finira par croiser
celui d'Helen McGinnis mais n'allons pas
trop vite
[Musique]
l'année suivant l'établissement des contacts
helen a commencé  travailler au
parc provincial du Niagara d'abord en tant que
chauffeur de navette, puis en tant que superviseur J'ai
adoré J'ai adoré J'ai adoré rencontrer différentes
personnes du monde entier Je veux dire
où pouvez-vous travailler où rencontrer
tous les différents types de personnes et travailler
avec  tous les différents types de personnes et
comme je dis les gens paient des milliers de
dollars pour venir ici et je peux le voir
tous les jours
c'est c'était c'était  amusante pendant l'
entretien de routine du parc, elle a remarqué un employé
portant un équipement de protection pulvérisant des
pesticides le long des trottoirs et dans le
parking, il avait une
chose de type combinaison blanche sur des bottes en caoutchouc, des gants, un masque
était entièrement recouvert d'une cagoule, vous savez,
il était donc protégé là où je n'étais pas  J'étais
inquiet à ce sujet parce que je pouvais le
goûter lors d'un autre incident, un collègue
est tombé malade après avoir été exposé à l'
herbicide. Helen s'inquiétait également du fait que les
visiteurs du parc étaient exposés
à tous, pas seulement aux enfants, mais aux adultes, et
tout le monde y était même exposé.
bien qu'il soit peut-être parti
trois heures avant, il est toujours dans les airs,
elle en parle à son représentant de la santé et de la sécurité,
mais la pulvérisation
continue oui oui oui cela a duré de
nombreuses années, je veux dire tout le temps où j'étais
là au printemps et  tout au long de l'
été, ils venaient et vaporisaient
Helen pense qu'elle aurait pu être exposée
à des produits comme le Roundup environ 50 fois
à Toronto à peu près au même moment
les choses vont bien pour Ian Monroe et
sa nouvelle entreprise Ken parle
des programmes majeurs des départements au moins
il met son expérience au service d'
une industrie avec une réputation notoire
goûte l'industrie du tabac c'est des années
avant que les scandales massifs ne soient révélés
qui ont montré comment les compagnies de tabac se cachaient
les dangers du tabagisme r.j.  Reynolds
poursuivait un projet secret dont le but était
d'aider l'entreprise à éviter la réglementation en
vertu de la Loi sur les aliments et drogues du Canada pour
approcher Santé Canada r.j.  Reynolds a
utilisé ian monroe, ces documents confirment
que Ian Monroe a eu deux
réunions confidentielles avec son ancien patron et
ami personnel, le sous
-ministre adjoint de l'époque, ils ont discuté de la façon dont r.j.
Reynolds pourrait être exempté de
signaler les niveaux de goudron d'un nouveau
produit de cigarette le projet a
finalement été abandonné au fil des ans
les contrats cantock Swan des gouvernements fédéral et
provincial il a également été embourbé
dans de multiples controverses vous savez
que c'est un Nicky dans lequel la batterie ne les appelle
pas  donc 1998 can't ox a été embauché pour
évaluer les risques pour la santé posés par 700
000 tonnes de boues toxiques laissées après le
démantèlement d'une centrale au charbon à Sydney, en Nouvelle-Écosse, je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
préoccupation pour le moment, nous avons examiné
les données qui sont  disponible en ce moment
il n'y a aucune inquiétude du
point de vue de la santé, les pourparlers ont conclu qu'il
n'y avait aucun risque pour votre santé en
conclusion la bombe à éphédrine était assez
facile à descendre jianchi a fait que vous savez
autonome je ne peux pas accepter le rapport can tox
serait plus tard sévèrement critiqué
par d'autres experts en 1999 peut pourparlers a été
embauché pour aider à l'expansion proposée de la raffinerie Irving
a Chevy Nova galette démocratique
Elizabeth nous sommes une équipe de tournage g
overnment univer bands week i retardé seulement kappa
blanka irving oil sola père Abba
Père une élasticité du sang peut parler
artefacts associés réputation de
l'atelier les favelas dans les entreprises unité
République Chan pourparlers a finalement acquis une
réputation internationale en rédigeant des
évaluations des risques pour les plastiques chlore
additifs alimentaires et industries des pesticides
et finalement pour Monsanto cela aura
des conséquences importantes pour Helen
McGinnis dont la vie va bientôt prendre une
tournure inattendue
une salle d'audience en Californie a été le théâtre
d'une bataille épique en 2018 le jury a jugé
l'entreprise responsable d'avoir permis à l'
homme de contracter un cancer do-seong  Le catalan
ne fait pas de logique dans l'Atlantique américain
en vente signale votre immédiat les
dommages ont ensuite été réduits à 78 millions de
dollars la vie ne cause pas le cancer,
il est parfaitement sûr et cela a été
démontré pendant plus de quatre décennies
Monsanto depuis son rachat par Bayer a
dû  se défendre contre les
allégations qui ont été faites à tr  iales
allégations faites dans des documents internes
que Brent Wisner, un avocat des
plaignants dans l'affaire, s'est battu pour rendre
public selon Brent ces
documents judiciaires connus sous le nom de documents de Monsanto
montrent comment Monsanto a travaillé pour créer le doute
sur la science qui remettait en question la
sécurité du hasard dans le cadre de  le
PlayBook qu'ils ont obtenu des
années du tabac sur la façon de faire de la science
dans le but de discréditer la bonne science - de
sorte que le doute Brent dit que Monsanto a caché des
études alors que nous montrons des études que Monsanto
a faites qui montrent des risques réels qui ont
été enterrés  qui n'ont jamais été donnés à aucune
agence de réglementation jamais donnés à la
communauté scientifique Linda a rencontré étrangement
prolifique un spinetto moyen une dilution
peut avoir commis une substance agent actif
c'est la fin des années 1990 un
nombre croissant d'études indépendantes trouvent d'
éventuels effets toxiques du
glyphosate et du roundup
Monsanto a embauché un chercheur britannique renommé
, James Perry, pour se pencher sur ce
dr.  Perry a conclu que le domaine viager et la
rafle sont potentiellement toxiques pour Gino et
peuvent causer des dommages liés au cancer, il
suggère des études supplémentaires la réponse
de l'un des responsables de Monsanto, nous
voulons trouver quelqu'un qui peut être influent
auprès des régulateurs lorsque Gino parle de problèmes,
ma lecture est que Perry est  pas
actuellement une telle personne Monsanto en
réponse et nous l'avons dans les documents
directement dit que nous n'allons pas faire
ces études que vous savez que ce type était
censé être notre porte-parole sur ces
questions et il ne l'est pas et donc ils n'ont jamais
soumis cela  le rapport à l'EPA est en
fait une violation de la loi fédérale,
ils ne l'ont jamais soumis à Santé Canada
Monsanto dit qu'il a mené des
études supplémentaires comme suggéré par le dr.  Perry et
n'a trouvé aucun G aucun effet toxique du
glyphosate ou de ses formulations, nous ne
savons pas dr.  L'opinion de Perry sur le fait qu'il est
décédé depuis
[Musique]
mais les problèmes soulevés par le dr.  Perry a
laissé présager d'autres problèmes pour Monsanto
une étude sur les agriculteurs canadiens a signalé un
lien entre la vie à part dans un type de
cancer appelé lymphome non hodgkinien un
employé de Monsanto a écrit Je commencerai à
travailler là-dessus au cas où les choses ne
changent pas et que le papier obtienne des médias
attention et il dit de l'étude canadienne que
la qualité des données n'est peut
-être pas excellente pour Monsanto mais
John McLaughlin l'un des principaux auteurs de l'étude
est aujourd'hui parmi les
experts les plus respectés du pays il est
scientifique en chef pour la santé publique
Ontario nous étions  scientifiquement surpris
parce qu'il n'y avait aucune preuve antérieure
du tout que le glyphosate était un
facteur de risque pour l'un de ces cancers, mais
une fois qu'il est apparu dans notre étude, nous n'avons
eu qu'à le signaler lorsque l'étude canadienne a
été publiée. Monsanto est heureux que
le mot  le glyphosate n'apparaît pas dans
le résumé de l'article, un grand pas en avant
écrit le toxicologue en chef de Monsanto, il l'
empêche d'être repris par les
résumés  Aujourd'hui, Monsanto remet toujours en
question la validité de cette étude canadienne,
le monde l'a traitée par d'autres
études examinant la même question,
puis au cours des prochaines années, quelques autres
études de conception et d'approche similaires ont en
fait rapporté la même chose dans les
années suivantes Monsanto  a travaillé en étroite collaboration
avec des scientifiques renommés sur le glyphosate,
mais un mot continue d'apparaître dans les
articles de Monsanto, ce qui soulève des doutes
sur certaines de ces études, ce mot est une
écriture fantôme,
c'est-à-dire lorsque quelqu'un écrit un article en
partie ou en totalité et plutôt que de signer
son propre nom cite d'autres
experts indépendants  qui sont considérés comme plus crédibles
et puis en même temps que ces
études sortent, Monsanto fait des
études fantômes qui disent le
contraire, l'une de ces études
deviendra la référence
selon Monsanto, elle est publiée en
2000 et a conclu que l'
herbicide Roundup ne pose pas de problème de santé  risque pour l'
homme l'étude est signée par trois
scientifiques Williams Crows et Mo  nroe
que Monroe est Ian Monroe, l'ancien fonctionnaire de
Santé Canada maintenant président de
peut parler, mais c'est ainsi qu'un
employé de Monsanto des années plus tard se réfère à cette
étude, nous réduirions les coûts
en faisant l'écriture et ils se
contenteraient de modifier et de signer leurs noms  pour ainsi
dire, rappelez-vous que c'est ainsi que nous avons traité les
corbeaux Williams à Monroe mm, soyons
très clairs sur ce qui ne peut pas être un
bœuf, ce n'est pas un groupe indépendant de
scientifiques proposant des critiques scientifiques,
ils pourraient prétendre être cela, mais ce n'est
pas ce qu'ils  sont-ils des institutions
ici pour fournir l'avis scientifique
que les industries veulent l'auteur principal de
l'étude Gary Williams dit que cela
ne s'est pas produit Monsanto qui a depuis
été racheté par Bayer nie également catégoriquement
ces allégations l'auteur a
révélé avoir bénéficié du
soutien scientifique de Monsanto  au procès, le
juge a été réceptif à cet argument
sous serment, un employé de Monsanto a
expliqué qu'il avait apporté des modifications mineures à
l'étude f  ou par souci de clarté, ce n'est
pas ce que Bill hiden a dit dans son e-mail, je
veux dire qu'il l'a bien dit ici car le jour c'est
ce que nous avons fait comme dans l'autre,
nous y allons fort, ce sont ses mots mais un autre
e-mail de Monsanto - can tox montre que
Monsanto  a eu le dernier mot, je réviserai
le manuscrit final avant
qu'il ne soit envoyé à l'éditeur, a écrit quand un
employé de Monsanto, puis dans un
message privé à un collègue, peut penser que
je leur laisserais en fait le montage final
sans supervision
[Musique]
en 2002, Henan McKenna avait  travaille
au Niagara Falls Park depuis plus de 15
ans, sa santé
s'est rapidement détériorée, on lui a
diagnostiqué un type rare de cancer, un
lymphome non hodgkinien.
J'étais
tellement bouleversée que j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique
pour que mon mari vienne me chercher
à l'hôpital Eve ma voiture là-bas, je
ne pouvais même pas conduire chez moi et j'étais
prête à vomir et tout parce que c'est
juste que je  c'est un choc c'est quelque chose que vous allez
à l'hôpital en pensant que vous avez la
grippe et que vous découvrez que c'est un cancer les médecins
ne savent pas comment Hannon a eu ce cancer
elle a rapidement commencé une chimiothérapie alors c'est
à ce moment-là qu'ils m'ont commencé ce que je ne sais pas
le nom de la terminologie, mais ils l'ont
appelé le diable rouge parce que c'était un
produit chimique très très dur qu'ils devaient
vous faire passer pour tuer
les cellules la maladie l'a forcée à arrêter de
travailler quand vous avez une chimiothérapie vous
développez ce qu'ils appellent un  brouillard où ta
mémoire n'est pas donc je faisais de nombreuses
erreurs que je n'aurais pas dû faire si je
ne peux pas faire le travail alors il est temps de partir
en 2010 le cancer est revenu après le
traitement Helen est de nouveau entrée en
rémission à des
milliers de kilomètres  en
Californie, vous tous, ils ne savent pas que je suis un
lutteur antiparasitaire intégré / grouseman
qui se salit tous les jours un
jardinier professionnel est sur le point de devenir le
pire cauchemar de Monsanto Lee Johnson ici lors d'une
visite à Toronto a fait la une des journaux
autour du monde depuis qu'il a remporté une
affaire révolutionnaire contre Monsanto, mais
le père de 47 ans qui est aussi
rappeur à ses heures perdues mène une
bien plus grande bataille contre le cancer, le
médecin m'a dit que je manquais de tic
TOCs la vie touche à sa fin  et
tout pourrait bientôt arrêter les médecins sur
la liste de paie, ils ont choisi un œil attentif, ils
ne se soucient vraiment pas de savoir si nous vivons ou mourons, alors
voici pop ce pop qui pourrait aussi
bien vivre parce que ce n'est pas un remède
pour ce
Lee Johnson  est maintenant traité pour
un lymphome non hodgkinien et les
lésions cutanées douloureuses associées à cette
maladie son cancer et ce qui l'a causé est
au cœur de son combat avec le
géant de la chimie Je ne parle vraiment pas de
Monsanto lui-même comme même en disant qu'ils
avaient raison  là, je ne dis généralement pas
l'entreprise ou les dis ou quoi que ce soit
parce que oui, ce n'est pas mon département pour
entrer dans la science ou quoi que ce soit, mais je
sais que c'est dans la preuve et
le jury a vu cela à propos de la science son
cancer  est apparu pour la première fois alors qu'il travaillait
comme paysagiste dans diverses écoles de la région de
San Francisco certains jours, il
pulvérisait des centaines de litres de désherbant
et on lui a dit que le produit était
sûr, un entraîneur est descendu et s'est assis à
table avec nous et a dit  nous que c'était
assez sûr pour boire ouais je ne sais pas
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit, je suis assez sûr
pour boire lee johnson portait un
équipement de protection mais malgré la prudence, son
équipement est tombé en panne et il a été trempé
par les lésions d'herbicide puis est apparu
sur  son cancer de la peau a été confirmé en 2014,
donc la façon dont j'ai réagi à cela était est-ce que je
vais mourir et ils disent eh bien tu
ne devrais pas mourir de ça mais oui ça peut
te tuer donc c'était assez difficile à prendre
que j'étais assez difficile à prendre  il n'y a
pas beaucoup de réponses pour cette maladie
Lee a appelé le service client de Monsanto
oui, donc le premier appel était en
novembre 2014, il venait de recevoir un
diagnostic de cancer, il appelle
Monsanto est hé, cela pourrait-il être lié
à ce genre de choses, je ne sais pas  ave toute autre
exposition, je suis juste curieux de savoir si c'est
lié, c'est résumé, la personne prend
toutes ses informations et dit que
nous vous répondrons,
ce n'est pas le cas. La demande de Lee n'a jamais reçu de
réponse à l'automne 2014.
Monsanto a un problème beaucoup plus important.
Je suis Donna Farmer Je suis une
scientifique de Monsanto et je suis maman La
responsable de Monsanto Donna Farmer envoie un
e-mail à ses collègues ce qui nous
préoccupe depuis longtemps s'est produit le
glyphosate est en cours pour un examen de l'arc en
mars 2015
ses craintes se sont réalisées  le
Centre international de recherche sur le
cancer a statué que le glyphosate est un
cancérogène probable, cela se fait en
examinant l'ensemble de la littérature mondiale de
recherche publiée dans de nombreux
domaines différents John McLaughlin dont le travail a été
critiqué par Monsanto il y a 20 ans faisait
partie de cette décision, il était l'un des
ceux sélectionnés par le comité des Nations Unies pour
étudier les risques associés au
glyphosate La classification des dangers du CIRC
était basée sur des preuves le processus la
pratique ils la rigueur avec laquelle  cela a
été fait était solide comme le roc
Monsanto est totalement en désaccord avec la décision
dit que la société contredit la
position de la plupart des autorités réglementaires
du monde entier, elle est biaisée et basée
sur la science indésirable dit que la science indésirable de Monsanto
était un terme qui a été créé par
l'industrie du tabac pour essayer de  discréditer
la science qui suggérait que le
tabagisme et la fumée secondaire étaient une cause
de cancer, alors j'ai presque ri,
c'est comme oh ça y
est, la décision du comité est critiquée
par des journalistes universitaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les coulisses, Monsanto a participé à l'
organisation  cette réponse le plan était de
lever le doute sur la pertinence de l'IRS Les
employés de Monsanto ont proposé de publier des articles
qui contredisaient les résultats de l'IRS ils ont
même suggéré d'écrire eux-mêmes ces études
pour réduire les coûts en quelques mois
15 experts ont rédigé une série d'
articles scientifiques affirmant que le
glyphosate n'était pas dangereux ils ont
présenté  eux-mêmes en tant que
scientifiques indépendants bien que 12  des 15 avaient
travaillé comme consultants de Monsanto dans
le passé, il y avait quelque chose qui semblait
particulièrement remarquable dans le moment
et la force du
tollé immédiat qui s'est produit à ce moment-là
Monsanto a embauché une société de conseil basée en Ontario
appelée inter tech pour
diriger le projet Intertek  était auparavant
connue sous le nom de Kent ox, la même entreprise qui a
été fondée par l'ancien responsable de Santé
Canada Ian Monroe ne peut pas ox a en fait
évolué pour devenir l'entreprise appelée inter
tech et la première chose que Monsanto a
faite la première chose qu'elle a faite lorsqu'elle a
découvert que le CIRC  l'avait classé comme
un cancérigène humain probable, c'est qu'ils ont
payé beaucoup d'argent pour entrer dans la technologie pour faire une
revue scientifique indépendante de citation et
qui a été publiée dans cinq ou six
articles différents qui ont tous été
soigneusement sculptés soigneusement contrôlés
et des parties soigneusement écrites par
Employés de Monsanto, il est difficile de savoir
quel était le rôle exact de l'intertexte. L'entreprise a
été embauchée et payée par Monsanto,
mais wa  est-ce un tampon ou un intermédiaire ou
même le fait qu'il a été orchestré
par l'industrie suggère que ce n'est pas du tout
indépendant le fait qu'ils nous aient créé
ces nouvelles publications ou qu'ils aient bien
organisé la publication de choses
ce n'est en fait pas comme ça que la bourse
fonctionne soit nous  écrivons nos propres articles et
nous faisons notre propre travail voici quelques
échanges de courriels entre Monsanto et Inter
tech qui montrent comment l'entreprise a
suivi de près l'écriture 6 janvier 2016
merci pour les mises à jour sur les essais bio animal
en résumé chapitre j'avais déjà
écrit le  brouillon du chapitre d'introduction
, puis vient la question de savoir qui
devrait être l'auteur ultime vous ou
Gary le même jour un autre article je pense que
vous et moi devrions parler de la façon dont ce
chapitre est terminé car ce n'est pas
exactement ce à quoi je m'attendais
le 13 janvier voici mes modifications suggérées
Le 8 février d'Intertek, veuillez jeter un
coup d'œil aux dernières nouvelles du
groupe d'épidémiologie le lendemain Monsanto dit ok
j'ai parcouru l'intégralité de la doc  ument
et indiqué ce que je pense devrait rester
dans ce qui peut aller les auteurs ont tous dit dans
leur déclaration d'intérêts qu'aucun
employé de la société Monsanto n'a examiné l'un
des manuscrits des groupes d'experts avant
de le soumettre au journal c'est un
mensonge plat et en fait à cause du
travail  nous avons fait le journal qui
les a publiés est en fait sorti et a
dit oh nous avons fait des erreurs
les auteurs ont depuis corrigé leurs
déclarations ils disent maintenant que trois
des articles ont fait l'objet de
révisions mineures et que la société n'a pas
influencé leurs conclusions pour  les panélistes ont
cependant admis avoir été payés
directement par l'entreprise pour leur
contribution tous les auteurs se sont excusés
ces articles n'étaient pas vraiment des
articles scientifiques un peu plus comme une opinion
un éditorial un relook du
point de vue de ces personnes il n'est pas
surprenant d'apprendre finalement que  eh bien,
c'était en fait influencé par l'industrie
elle-même, je mettrais une très grande explication
sur la qualité et je  L'intégrité de ces
papiers quelques jours après que le typhus 8 est
considéré comme un cancérogène probable par le CIRC
L'équipement de Lee Johnson se casse à nouveau pour la
deuxième fois sa peau est trempée il est
inquiet et appelle à nouveau la société deux
semaines après la décision du CIRC d'accord il le
rappelle son  le cancer
s'aggrave, il commence à se propager et il est un
peu très inquiet, ils
lui disent qu'ils le rappelleront et ils ne le font pas et
donc il traverse une autre
saison de pulvérisation entière et pendant ce temps, son
cancer passe d'être indolent et
contrôlable à être une condamnation à mort
bon après-midi mesdames et messieurs
du jury au procès le jury a statué en
leur faveur
ils ont conclu que la rafle peut causer
un lymphome non hodgkinien qu'il s'agissait d'un
facteur important dans l'affaire Johnsons
ils ont également statué que Monsanto n'avait pas
suffisamment  informer le public des
dangers des rafles
malgré les objections de Monsanto le juge a
confirmé le verdict Monsanto fait appel de
la décision et dit qu'il ne
ref  lire l'état actuel de la science
quel que soit l'avenir Lee Johnson est
prêt tout le monde doit mourir tout le monde
doit mourir un jour alors vous savez qu'ils disent qu'un
lâche meurt mille morts un soldat
meurt une fois que vous savez je veux dire alors ouais je
ne suis pas un lâche  Je n'ai pas peur de mourir tu
sais mais si je dois mourir Elise Howard est
morte pour quelque chose
ni Intertek ni monsanto n'ont répondu directement
à nos questions spécifiques
qui travaille 1 200 acres
de terre dans des masques à OG Québec et comme
la majorité des agriculteurs à travers le
pays, il utilise un herbicide à base de typhus 8
sur son maïs
j'ai dit FS presque en disant qu'il sentait
cette chose que je veux cueillir alors il a détourné
spondoolie désolé le slapper alors  la magie sur
son c'est si fade
mais la magie du glyphosate a cédé la
place à l'inquiétude des agriculteurs qui sont les plus
exposés au produit sont pris au
milieu
[Musique]
Mikey dissident Kansai Trojan trois
douzaines sont tw  o plutôt la même anatomie
verra l'examen du nom du réseau, il
lancera une touche de souris Je ne vois pas où le
Canada a été le premier
pays industrialisé à renouveler le glyphosate après qu'il a été
classé comme cancérogène probable par le
CIRC, le gouvernement a déclaré que cette décision
était basée sur  science
seuls quelques scientifiques au Québec étudient le
glyphosate aliskiren budva est l'un d'
entre eux elle a examiné comment différents
pesticides affectent le corps humain elle a
testé Dreyfus a mangé seul ainsi que la
formulation de rafle dalla Coco circuit un
exposé autour de notre propre ave verum entrez
sebastian de la  illaha matado imprimeur
Sebastian Cedella production le député
allemand cet œstrogène a permis ses
conclusions sont préliminaires mais d'autres
études confirment ses résultats voir vous voyez
comparer Sebastian l'
œstrogène de reproduction cssc sont le problème de Santi
occupation œdème lumière seconde une Paloma
savait dépendre de Caracas en dehors de
budhwa kahan a trouvé ces  résultats avec
rafle seulement le problème est que le Canada
n'approuve pas la rafle o  r la centaine
d'autres formulations commerciales, il
n'approuve que l'ingrédient principal
glyphosate
petit lecteur de dinde Je peux voir Nokomis MK
nu un Maidana actif vraiment picotant est
un actif parfois c'est facile à vendre donc
c'est plus facile pour moi
Liza donna pas Mata régulière  n'est que pour moi des
mensonges, certains chiots et le
sac à main Costello posant comme une pierre La limite logique FET de Seon
n'est que bourdonnante c'est totalement l'
allergie à NeatDesk qui n'est pas Santé
Canada a récemment renouvelé l'
enregistrement du glyphosate pour 15 autres années depuis
le renouvellement huit objections formelles ont été
déposées  par des médecins universitaires et
des groupes environnementaux, y compris aquí de
la haute originale Monsanto Donna simple
le saké Canada, ils ont adouci la vérité
alors là nous voyons le rassemblement Soho voir Cesar
à Lucas quelque chose peut je n'aime pas le
schéma copain
la route des sit-down vient juste de sortir  sur
Yankovic, c'est que Santé Canada affirme que
les objections ne sont pas étayées par la
science et que le glyphosate ne
présente pas de risque pour l'homme  s ou l'environnement
aux niveaux d'exposition actuels malgré ce que
les papiers de Monsanto disent que le glyphosate
restera sur le marché pour faire son
évaluation finale le gouvernement s'est appuyé en partie
sur 118 études toxicologiques dont
111 sont restées confidentielles et ont été
fournies par Monsanto en fait les
trois quarts des  les études sur la
santé humaine ont été fournies par l'industrie, d'
autre part, le
CIRC ne s'est appuyé que sur des recherches publiées
évaluées par des pairs la décision finale a été
prise sur un nombre relativement faible
pour lequel il était clair qu'ils
avaient une bonne mesure une bonne conception une bonne
analyse nous avons besoin du ministre  de Santé
Canada a refusé qu'un groupe d'
experts indépendants examine la décision,
le simple fait est
que les organismes de réglementation conçus pour nous protéger
nous ont
laissé tomber Brent Wisner, l'avocat américain qui combat le
glyphosate, a bravé
les températures glaciales d'Ottawa pour
venir rencontrer des députés canadiens  exigeons que nos
autorités de réglementation travaillent pour nous et
non pour elles jusqu'à ce que cela se produise, nous sommes
n  ne va pas voir de grands changements, il est venu
leur dire que Santé Canada est sur la mauvaise
voie, les données qui sont actuellement
examinées n'ont pas fait l'objet d'
un examen indépendant par des pairs et, à cause de
cela, nous ne connaissons pas vraiment les
appels au jugement scientifique qui ont contribué à la fabrication
cette décision et je pense que cela peut être un
vrai problème pour la santé publique la
sécurité du glyphosate reste le sujet de
débat et les agences de régulation
du monde entier continuent de réapparaître
malgré la décision des pirates Sikkim Emmer
n'a pas pu prendre une clé pour moi l'expiré
mmm ouais je vois le  deux nouveaux permis
qu'ils achètent mais je ne suis pas d'accord sur ce sont des
gens comme des créatures iconiques gonflées une
place dans le précurseur de la couleur de la souris
au Canada l'industrie n'est pas restée les bras croisés
par ce courriel de Monsanto montre comment
le lobby agricole a envisagé de demander
au gouvernement canadien  arrêter de financer le
CIRC, c'est dérangeant et cela n'a
rien à voir avec l'avancement réel de la
science, rien à voir avec l'amélioration de la
santé, la protection de la santé ou de l'e  Même en
aidant à produire de la nourriture pour la planète,
ce sur quoi l'entreprise pourrait
se concentrer, nous ne savons pas si cette
demande a jamais été satisfaite, mais rien de tout
cela ne me rassure.
télévision
panier mou il s'appuie sur Santé Canada
ce converti a dit par besoin est amanda
kenneth e PF idée spectacle Pete je veux dire le
secrétaire a comparé le styliste à Santé
Canada a accordé une entrevue à nos
collègues de Lessman vet et leap III
mais a refusé de nous parler dans son
examen final Santé Canada a trouvé déconcertantes
les affirmations de citations incorrectes ou trompeuses
dans des études effectuées par des techniciens
ou des contacts et bien que ces études
aient été utilisées pour réprouver le glyphosate, ils ont
déclaré que les articles n'avaient pas eu d'incidence sur
la décision finale
aux États-Unis cette année, sept
poursuites supplémentaires sont en cours  prévu contre Monsanto des
milliers d'autres sont en attente l'
affaire Johnson n'est pas terminée l'appel
interjeté par Bayer sera bientôt hea  rd mais
quel que soit le résultat, Lee Johnson est
convaincu que mon équipe juridique a dit
qu'il passerait des années d'appels, ces
appels pourraient vous survivre, vous pourriez être
parti, mais au moins vous n'êtes pas
censé faire pour votre famille, c'est ce qui
fait  tu te sens bien
[Musique]
20:18 a été une mauvaise année pour Helen McGinnis,
son cancer est revenu pour la troisième fois, il
vous contrôle, il vous ronge l'esprit
et quand il revient, dites simplement que
vous savez pourquoi moi, mais il y a une raison et
nous ne savons pas qu'Helen est ici pour rencontrer son
oncologue afin d'obtenir ses derniers
résultats de test elle est impatiente de savoir quelle est la
prochaine étape la question est vraiment de savoir quel
avantage vous allez retirer de l'
adresse Helen ne saura jamais avec certitude
ce qui a causé son cancer  elle pense maintenant que cela
pourrait être lié à ses multiples
expositions à arrondir, c'est donc à ce moment-là que
j'ai traversé l'indemnisation des accidents du travail, mais j'ai
été refusé parce qu'ils ont dit qu'il n'y
avait pas assez d'informations, ils
ne pensaient pas que cela avait une incidence sur les
non-hodgkins l  l'
indemnisation des accidents du travail du ymphome en Ontario a pris cette
décision avant que je ne sois jugé que le glyphosate est
un cancérigène probable l'une des études
utilisées pour rejeter l'affirmation d'Helens a conclu
que le glyphosate n'était ni cancéreux ni
génotoxique cette étude a été rédigée par
Williams crows et Ian Munroe des
conduites il existe des
versions contradictoires  quant à la façon dont cela ne peut pas ox papier
s'est réuni, mais cette note de
Monsanto datant de 2000
révèle qu'un cadre supérieur remercie
plusieurs employés pour la collecte de données
mais aussi pour leur rédaction et leur édition
can tox est également remercié avec la
société de relations publiques pour  leurs
modifications infinies dans les critiques, elle invite les employés
à utiliser l'article pour construire autour des
voiles
[Musique]
helen réagit bien à son
traitement c'est une bonne nouvelle définitivement je
dis une mission oui mais je continue juste à me
battre et et je vais le battre
avant ça  me bat disons comme ça
je vais être là pour te reparler
de ça fais moi confiance
ken parle ça n'existe plus
l'ancien président et fondateur de Egan
Monroe est décédé d'un cancer en 2011 avant de
mourir il a laissé un million et demi de
dollars à son alma mater l'
université McGill à Montréal la chaire en
sécurité alimentaire porte maintenant son nom
[Musique]